[Music]
in Colorado Leafs by Snoop okay is
something that you've launched you got
not just pot you got edibles all right
now tell us do you you like edibles and
how do you incorporate edibles into your
life well me personally I don't really
agree with edibles because they have a
button that's the own button but they
don't have an off button he comes to me
right you know and I don't like not
being in control so I'd rather not but
for those who do who don't you know
prefer to smoke it's the best high
quality CPD you know it's stopping the
line you know I'm saying this is to do
it fluid it's the do it fluid all right
now whatever time I did we probably
that's something that like like you know
there was one guy on my staff and he'll
go nameless producer Dan Ferguson and he
just a love you know his pot in his
edibles and I remember what she was like
looking I was looking at the stuff he
had he had like a baby pacifier made out
of a pod you would like long long long
long you know I mean there
[Applause]
I caught him ah I caught him a mustache
before what's that I caught that guy in
mustache yeah that listen they have all
kinds of stuff now they have creams
there's bath salts last week we had a
sex expert on the show and I'm not
kidding she had a spray that had what
THC in it and you're you're a woman is
supposed to spray it in her nether
regions
Oh to increase pleasure and she said
it's becoming a big thing have you tried
the sprays out at all not know sexual
medically marijuana tricks or none of
that I've I try but I've heard and I've
heard they're very well so would you be
interested that you think you would try
that I might I might I might yeah I'm
not saying that you're not gonna tell me
I might you know what let's try it on
Larry King okay yeah happy to do we wait
we wait till Larry King's at naught at
the urinal Larry
you